decenas de manifestantes fueron
arrestados en la calle de minsk este
domingo un día después de que la policía
detuviera a cientos de personas durante
una marcha de mujeres en la capital del
país las autoridades llevaron camiones
militares al centro de minsk decenas de
miles de manifestantes marcharon por la
avenida central de la capital hacia el
palacio de la independencia fuertemente
custodiado allí tiene sus oficinas el
asediado presidente alexander lukashenko
las protestas contra el gobierno también
se replicaron en otras ciudades así los
manifestantes también se encontraron con
una fuerte presencia policial
belarús es escenario de un agitado
movimiento antigubernamental desde que
lukashenko reclamara una victoria
aplastante en las elecciones del 9 de
agosto unos comicios que según la
oposición fueron fraudulentos desde
entonces los opositores al gobierno han
permanecido en las calles y durante ese
tiempo se han enfrentado a una brutal
represión policial también a la cárcel
ya presuntas torturas la policía
bielorrusa a menudo se cubre la cara con
máscaras pasamontañas o cascos en
respuesta a estos piratas informáticos
anónimos filtraron los datos personales
de mil agentes
hace semanas la unión europea prometió
imponer sanciones a belarús por presunto
fraude electoral y abusos de los
derechos humanos contra los
manifestantes aunque es probable que el
bloque no cumpla con el plazo del lunes
para tomar medidas
lukashenko ha estado en el poder durante
26 años y no muestra intenciones de
dimitir pronto aunque la presión de los
manifestantes se mantiene firme el
mandatario cuenta con el apoyo del
presidente ruso vladimir putin quien
acordó prestarle a sus gobiernos 1.500
millones de dólares como muestra de
apoyo